Rhett: Alright, so what I'm doing right now is I'm spacing all of the feet 16 inches apart
And I'm pre-drilling holes in it so I don't have to switch the bit every time.
Then I'm gonna take the wood screws and go all the way down, and the base board will be complete.
Once we have these going up all the way down the wall, we should be able to fit about 65 guns going down
Which...should be enough?
Sam: What's up?
We're going back to the tried and true method of doing a 3D scan with the Kinect.
It's always handy to have a 3D model of somebody for a video to shoot.
3D scanning people is actually incredibly easy. You just need a good program and a Kinect.
We're using an application called "Ska-nect"
Plug it in, make sure it's all working, aim it at your subject, hit record.
Basically, you can scan it around, move it around, or in our case, just have the subject spin in place.
(To wren) Also kinda keep your hands out to your sides instead of out like this, yeah.
Rhett: More than enough room for the guns.
Based on the amount that I fit in these three slots right here, I think we're doing pretty darn good when it comes to gun enclosures.
Alrighty, just waiting for things to dry right now and uhhh...
yeah we just got this busted out and
Wren went straight for the wettest part.
Sam: Holy S***.
Okay, guys, just look- look at this.
Pretty dark in here, isn't it?
Well, check out...this!
*Dssssh!*
That's a lot of guns.
Rhett: Dude I'm not even done unloading them either!
Sam: Like level zero, it's like totally chill,
it detected an intruder,
and then
threat level red is like-
Wren: OH MY GOD!!
Sam: Yeah.
Wren: OOOhhhhaahaa!
Sam: Dude, oh this is the creepy silent hill mode.
I'm gonna go try and fire this
Alright, ready?
We are recording
Aaaand it's going.
K, got it.
Everything is generally better on the top, the legs are a little jacked up.
Mmmmm this looks pretty good.
Any excess stuff you're not trying to scan, you just open up like 3DS MAX and just delete it.
Alright, not bad, not bad for 10 minutes of work.
Matrix shooting like "aaahhh!"